Let us now consider
a simple example.
Let random variables X and Y
be described by a joint PMF
which is the one shown
in this table.
Question--
are X and Y independent?
We can try to answer this
question by using the
definition of independence.
But it is actually more
instructive to proceed in a
somewhat more intuitive way.
We look at this table, and we
observe that the value of one
is possible for X. In
particular, the probability
that X takes the value of one,
this is the marginal
probability, this can be found
by adding the probabilities of
all of the outcomes in this
column, which, in this case,
is 3 over 20.
Suppose now that somebody tells
you the value of Y. For
example, I tell you that Y
happens to be equal to one, in
which case you are transported
into this universe.
In this universe, the
conditional probability that X
takes a value of one, given that
Y takes a value of one,
what is it?
In this universe, there's
zero probability
associated to this outcome.
So this probability
is zero, which is
different than 3 over 20.
And since these two numbers are
different, this means that
information from Y changes our
beliefs about what's going to
happen to X. And so, we do
not have independence.
So again, intuitively, in the
beginning, we thought that X
equal to one was possible.
But information given by Y,
namely that Y is equal to one,
tells us that, actually, X
equals to one is impossible.
Information about Y changed our
beliefs about X, so X and
Y are dependent.
Now, when we first introduced
the notion of independence
some time ago, we also
introduced the notion of
conditional independence.
And we said that conditional
independence is the same as
ordinary independence, except
that it would be applied to a
conditional universe.
Something similar can be done
for the case of random
variables as well.
So suppose, for example, that
someone tells us that the
outcome of the experiment
was such that it belongs
to this blue set.
This is the set where X is less
than or equal to 2, and Y
is larger than or
equal to three.
So we're given this information,
and this is now
our new conditional model.
The question is, within this
new conditional model are
random variables X and
Y independent?
Let's just right down the
conditional model, where I'm
only showing the four possible
outcomes that are allowed in
the conditional model.
All the others, of course, will
have zero probability in
the conditional model.
So in the conditional model,
probabilities will keep the
same proportions as in the
unconditional model--
and the proportions
are 1, 2, 2, 4--
but then they need to be scaled,
or normalized, so that
they add to 1.
And to make them add to 1, we
need to divide them all by 9.
In this conditional model, this
is the joint PMF of the
two random variables X and Y.
Let us find the marginal PMFs.
To find the marginal PMF
of X, we add the
entries in this column.
And we get here 1/3,
and here 2/3.
And to find the marginal
PMF of y, we add the
entries in this [row]
to find 2/3.
And we adds the entries
in that [row]
to find 1/3.
So this is the marginal
PMF of x.
That's the marginal PMF of Y.
And now we notice that this
entry of the joint PMF
is 1/3 times 1/3, the
product of the marginals.
This entry is the product of 1/3
times 2/3, the product of
the marginals, and so on for
the remaining entries.
So each entry of the joint PMF
is equal to the product of the
corresponding entries of
the marginal PMFs.
And this is the definition
of independence.
So in this conditional blue
universe, we do have
independence.
And the way that this was
established was to check that
the joint PMF factors as a
product of marginal PMFs.